This story struck me personally
because it has to do with Steven Spielberg.
Some Oscar controversy is heating up around town.
Deadline reports that the Oscars is cutting eight categories
from the telecast.
And Steven Spielberg is saying
he hopes they'll change their mind.
The Academy plans to leave out
several short film categories, plus production design
which we are literally just talking about,
how important it is.
Yeah.
Original score music can change
the whole way you feel about a scene
you are watching.
Film editing which is a complete art in itself.
You choose the takes from the actors.
You choose what pieces of the story to leave in and out.
Oh, and makeup and hair styling, what?
What, yeah, I know.
They will give these awards out before the show
and edit their acceptance speeches into the live telecast.
Spielberg, and a chorus of critics
are saying these categories deserve to share the stage
alongside of them.
And Steven has been quoted saying,
"There is no above the line and below the line,
which means, stars and crew."
I totally agree with him.
Steven has also said he is a complete fan
of the president of the academy.
This is also a network decision.
And I think they're just trying to find a way
to keep the pace alive,
but at what cost?
Exactly, we can't forget that movie making
is such a collaborative process.
As a fan, I want to see the people
who make the movies being celebrated.
That's the whole point.
Yes, yes!
You have to put on a good show
but you can't lose focus.
(audience cheers)
Yeah.
All right, next up,
if there is a little leap
that you're thinking of taking in your life,
no matter how big or small,
maybe this story will inspire you to just go for it.
The Week reports, "It's about to be a huge homecoming
for Tom Turcich.
On April 2nd, 2015, a day before he turned 26
Tom left his New Jersey home with one goal
to travel the entire world on foot."
Yeah, "Since then he's traveled over 25,000 miles.
Most of it with Savannah right here,
a dog that he adopted on a stop in Texas," oh Savannah!
"And now Tom has burned through 45 pairs of sneakers
traveling to the mountains of Kurdistan
following a flock of sheep in Iceland,
kayaking through Antarctica.
He was inspired to take this journey
when he was just 17 years old
because he lost a young friend
and he realized that he wanted to make the most of the time
we all have on this earth."
And now, I mean, this story.
(audience cheers)
Now believe this or not.
Now he is on day 1789 of his journey.
He's just weeks away from making it home,
walking around the entire world, what?
And I just hope that he brought his Fitbit
'cause can you imagine at the end you're like,
"Oh, man, I didn't."
(Drew laughs)
This story, it speaks to me so much
that we have these choices in life.
Yeah.
And I have so much respect
and admiration for his choices.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪